Donc, cette première leçon, on va rentrer dans un nouveau chapitre sur la confession de foi, c'est le chapitre 4.
C'est celui qui nous parle de la création.
Et le récit de la création, il est fondamental pour tout encadrement, je dirais théologique, mais aussi historique, de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Nous dépendons beaucoup des récits de Genèse pour comprendre les bases de l'histoire de la rédemption.
Nous dépendons beaucoup des Genèse pour comprendre l'anthropologie biblique, la conception biblique par rapport à ce qui est l'être humain,
les buts de son existence, l'explication pour ses principales crises actuelles.
Mais c'est aussi un texte qui a été traité, utilisé beaucoup dans la Bible.
Donc, quand on pense dans la structure interne de la parole des dieux, Ancien Testament et Nouveau Testament,
nous avons beaucoup des références vers Genèse, y compris de la part du Christ lui-même et des apôtres.
Et donc, ils ont tous fait un abordage assez historique du texte, assez littéral du texte.
Et donc, je pense que c'est l'une des portions des écritures les plus puissantes, les plus belles,
celles qui donnent le plus les sens d'existence et même la structure pour la compréhension de l'Évangile.
Et malheureusement, dans notre génération, et dans des générations un peu plus récentes,
car quand on considère l'ensemble de l'histoire de l'Église,
et nous allons considérer aussi ceux qui cherchent à raffirmer aussi la confession de foi,
on a toujours eu une interprétation majoritaire, historique, littéraire des Genèses.
Mais malheureusement, c'est quelque chose qui est plus ou moins sous attaque.
On est tombé dans une flexibilité que je trouve très dangereuse,
surtout depuis l'avènement de la popularisation de la théorie de l'évolution
et une pression qui a fait que certains théologiens cherchent une solution plus adaptée à ces théories.
Et c'est important pour nous de renforcer le fait qu'il s'agit des théories.
Mais pour moi, le plus important, et c'est mon objectif aujourd'hui,
c'est de faire une lecture.
Donc ça, c'est l'une des déclarations des réformés qui était l'une des plus importantes.
Normalement, la lecture la plus évidente du texte, c'est celle qui doit dicter la doctrine.
Donc normalement, la position la plus simple à partir des écritures, c'est celle qui a raison.
Ça se base sur un attribut des écritures sur lesquelles on a déjà basé, on a déjà parlé.
C'est la clarté, la perspécuté des écritures.
Et donc, quand on va faire la lecture naturelle du texte,
ce qui ressort le plus évident, c'est normalement là où on doit s'accrocher et ne pas négocier.
OK ?
Donc moi, je tiens à cœur la doctrine de la création
et Dieu le sait combien j'ai hâte d'aborder cette doctrine avec l'Église.
Mais comme on fait à chaque fois, la première leçon de chaque doctrine de la confession,
on essaye de rester surtout dans une ambientation avec les thèmes et les textes bibliques.
Et donc là, aujourd'hui, c'est ce qu'on va faire.
On va d'abord lire les articles de la confession de foi.
C'est trois paragraphes très concis.
Et ensuite, on va méditer surtout sur les premiers versets des Genèse chapitre 1.
Et on va chercher à avoir une expérience comme si on n'était pas né dans notre génération,
comme si l'école n'avait pas encore joué sur nos compréhensions de la création,
comme si la théologie moderne et post-moderne n'avaient pas encore joué sur notre compréhension.
On va essayer de faire un abordage plus neutre des Écritures
et chercher à considérer ce qui ressort de manière plus naturelle du texte biblique.
OK ?
Et donc ensuite, par rapport aux autres leçons,
on peut revenir et traiter les divergences doctrinaires à cet égard.
Donc, est-ce que vous avez la confession avec vous ?
Si quelqu'un peut nous lire les premiers paragraphes,
paragraphe 1 du chapitre 4 de la Création.
Au commencement, il a pu à Dieu, Père, Fils et Saint-Esprit,
pour la manifestation de sa gloire et de son éternelle puissance,
de sa sagesse et de sa volonté,
de créer ou de faire,
en six jours, le monde,
ainsi que tout ce qui se trouve,
chose visible et invisible,
et tout est extrêmement.
Super.
Donc là, on voit de manière très évidente
quelle est la position par rapport au jour des créations,
de la confession de foi.
C'est-à-dire, on est devant, en document orthodoxe, historique.
Et là,
« Décréer ou de faire en six jours,
les mondes,
ainsi que tous ces qui se trouvent,
chose visible et invisible,
et tout était très bon. »
Donc, juste pour qu'on ait à nouveau
une considération par rapport à l'ordre des doctrines
qu'on étudie,
dans la confession de foi,
on a commencé par les Écritures,
pour être sûrs
que nous devons nous assurer
que la Bible est la seule source fiable
de toute connaissance assurée des dieux.
OK ?
Et ensuite, on est passé à considérer Dieu.
C'est l'effet instant de la théologie,
c'est le but principal,
toute la Bible, toute l'histoire.
C'est un moyen de révélation des dieux
afin de révéler sa gloire
pour qu'ils nous ayuront
une relation d'adoration envers lui.
Et donc, le but central,
même l'Évangile,
est un moyen de réconciliation avec Dieu.
L'Évangile est à service
de l'adoration, de la relation avec Dieu.
Et donc, c'est un moyen
d'auto-révélation divine.
Et donc, la Bible étant la base,
on est passé à considérer
l'être des dieux et ses attributs.
Et donc, après avoir considéré Dieu
par rapport à ce qui est central
dans sa révélation de soi-même,
nous sommes passés à considérer
un autre moyen,
donc il y a un moyen direct
par lequel Dieu se révèle.
Les descriptions bibliques
par rapport à l'être des dieux
et ses attributs, etc.
Mais ensuite,
Dieu se révèle aussi
par ses œuvres.
Donc, on a considéré
l'être des dieux,
ses attributs.
Ensuite, on est passé à considérer
les noms des dieux aussi,
qui c'est une révélation aussi directe
de qui il est,
par des titres,
par des noms.
Et ensuite,
on a considéré,
on a commencé à considérer
la large ou les larges domaines
de la création
ou des œuvres des dieux plutôt.
et donc,
avant de faire de manière concrète
les choses,
Dieu a planifié les choses.
Et comme Dieu planifie
toutes les choses parfaitement,
on a considéré
ce qu'on appelle la doctrine
des décrets éternels de Dieu.
Tout ce que Dieu a planifié,
c'était un arrêt,
car c'est fondé
sur son intelligence infinie
et c'est aussi dépendant
de sa supervision,
de sa mise en exécution.
Et donc,
on a considéré
les décrets éternels des dieux
dans la dernière série
quand on a considéré
les chapitres 3.
Et donc,
il s'essuie naturellement
que maintenant,
on a vu
ce que Dieu a planifié
et maintenant,
on va voir
l'exécution
de ces plans des dieux,
donc l'œuvre des dieux.
Donc,
quand on étudie
la théologie systématique,
plusieurs commencent
par là,
par les six jours
des créations,
la création du monde
ou de l'univers.
OK ?
Mais,
comme il dit
six choses visibles
et invisibles,
et comme plusieurs
considèrent
qu'au commencement,
Dieu créa
les ciels et la terre,
donc cette référence
au ciel
comprend aussi
les anges,
il y en a plusieurs
théologiques thématiques
qui,
avant de considérer
la création
du monde matériel,
on considère
la création
des êtres spirituels
et on commence
à étudier par là
la doctrine des anges,
ce qu'on appelle
l'angiologie.
Donc,
la confession de foi,
elle va inclure
les anges
quand elle décrit
la création,
mais elle ne va pas
développer trop
la doctrine
à propos des anges.
Donc,
nous,
on va réfléchir encore
si on se plonge
là-dedans ou non
en faisant une parenthèse.
Moi,
je trouve toujours
très intéressant,
c'est possible
qu'on les fasse,
mais aujourd'hui,
on va s'habituer
surtout avec
Génès chapitre 1.
Donc,
qui peut lire
les paragraphes 2 ?
Après avoir fait
cette créature,
de ce cas-là,
il est très mal
et honnête,
avec des âmes
raisonnables
et immortelles,
il est rendu propre
à ce qui est
avec Dieu
pour laquelle
il s'est fait.
qui est un peu
en connaissance,
et en connaissance,
!
ayant la loi de Dieu
qui est un peu
dans leur cœur
et qui est un peu
dans leur cœur,
qui est un peu
dans leur cœur.
dans leur cœur,
qui est un peu
en connaissance,
dans leur cœur,
qui est un peu
de leur cœur,
dans leur cœur,
qui est un peu
capable de s'en sortir.
OK.
Donc ça,
ça va être
les thèmes
pour une deuxième étape.
On va commencer
par la considération
de la création
du monde et de l'univers
et ensuite,
donner encore plus
d'attention
à l'être humain
étant au centre
de cette création
comme image de Dieu.
Et paragraphe 3.
En plus de la loi
en crie dans leur cœur,
ils ont reçu
l'ordre de ne pas
manquer de l'âge
de la connaissance
du bien et du mal.
Tant qu'ils ont
observé ce commandement,
ils ont été heureux
dans leur communion
avec Dieu
et ont dominé
sur les créatures.
Super.
Donc voilà
la structure
que nous allons suivre.
OK.
Avec la considération
générale
de la création des dieux,
en suivant les rythmes
des écritures,
on va marcher toujours
de général
vers les particuliers,
l'être humain
étant au centre
et la relation
avec Dieu
étant encore plus
au centre.
OK.
Donc l'homme
fait à l'image
de Dieu
et cette relation
basilaire initiale,
la relation
avec Dieu
qui était
encadrée
par une possibilité
volontaire
de renoncer
la dépendance
et l'obéissance
à Dieu
ou d'être honoré,
être béni
par une récompense
si l'être humain
volontairement
préserve
sa soumission
à Dieu.
et donc là,
ce seront les trois
étapes
qu'on va traiter
dans les prochaines
leçons
et aujourd'hui,
c'est surtout
de nous habituer
avec Génèse
chapitre 1
et en cherchant
à faire cette
lecture naturelle
du texte.
Et donc,
verset 1,
c'est intéressant,
ça nous renvoie
à la notion
de la préexistence
des dieux.
La Bible,
elle ne cherche
jamais
à chercher
à défendre
l'existence
des dieux.
les faits
que Dieu existe,
c'est une déclaration
et c'est quelque chose
d'assumé
partout dans les Écritures.
Et ce qui est
le commencement
pour nous,
bien sûr,
c'est le commencement
du temps lui-même
car Dieu est un être éternel.
Il vit
dans une éternité
au-dessus du temps.
Il est celui
qui était,
qui est,
qui sera.
Il est le « je suis ».
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
qu'on a eu
parler du commencement,
bien sûr,
qui c'est le commencement
pour nous.
C'est notre perception
de comment les choses
ont commencé
pour nous.
Et donc,
au commencement,
Dieu,
et c'est intéressant,
il est déclaré
comme l'agent
qui va provoquer
les commencements
pour nous,
mais il est celui
qui est hors du temps,
préexistant,
ok,
de qui
toute l'existence
dépend,
mais lui-même
étant
l'existence
éternelle.
Donc,
toutes les choses
subsistent en lui,
mais lui,
il est l'auteur
de toutes les choses.
Et donc,
au commencement,
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre.
Et donc,
ici,
nous voyons,
on peut organiser un peu
ce qui compose
l'univers
dans lequel nous vivons.
On a
les temps,
on a
l'espace,
ok,
et on a
les,
ce qu'on appelle
la puissance
ou les mouvements.
temps,
espace,
matière
et puissance.
Donc,
la puissance
qui a engendré
toutes les choses,
c'est Dieu lui-même.
La matière,
c'est cette matière
qu'il a créée
pour former
la terre.
Les temps,
c'est les commencements
pour nous.
Et donc,
ici,
nous sommes devant
tous les composants
de ceux
qui comprennent
l'existence
telle qu'on la comprenne
et telle qu'il est scientifique
qui les comprenne aussi.
Et donc,
là,
nous sommes devant
une manière
très glorieuse
des dieux
car
il y a eu
un prix Nobel
qui a
réduit
l'existence
dans ces quatre éléments
puissance,
temps,
espace
et
matière.
Et là,
on voit que la Bible,
dès le départ,
elle déclare
ces éléments
de manière très claire.
Donc,
Dieu créa.
C'est très important
déjà de considérer
la terminologie.
Donc,
quand on parle
de ces termes
commencements,
difficilement,
il n'a jamais
été utilisé
dans leur contexte
historique
pour suggérer
une longue période
de temps.
Ça,
c'est très important.
C'est la lecture
la plus naturelle
et le plus probable,
c'est que cette référence
par rapport
au commencement,
c'est la période
des sept jours
qui sera décrite.
On ne parle pas
du commencement
quand on va dire
au commencement
de l'histoire,
on ne peut pas
attendre que les personnes
s'imaginent
que ces commencements
de l'histoire
durent longtemps.
C'est une période
qui caractérise
les débuts.
OK ?
Et c'est une période
qui sera décrite
naturellement
par les textes.
Donc,
au commencement,
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre.
Donc,
ici,
nous n'avons pas
un hasard
qui puisse jouer.
Donc,
ça,
c'est très important.
Le rien ne peut rien
créer.
Nous ne pouvons pas croire
à la préexistence
de la matière,
car même par rapport
à la théorie
de l'évolution,
pour qu'une explosion
ait lieu,
il y a les besoins
que certaines substances
existent.
OK ?
Et donc,
ici,
il y a non plus
même l'intérêt
de considérer
que Dieu aurait pu
créer ces substances,
mais après,
permettre qu'elles explosent
ou qu'elles évoluent
sous sa gouvernance,
car l'intentionnalité
du texte
nous déclare
de manière explicite
que cet être intelligent,
cet être personnel,
avec intentionnalité,
car la déclaration,
c'est au commencement,
Dieu créa
les ciels et la terre.
Et donc,
les mouvements bibliques,
ce n'est pas
pour suggérer
une espèce
d'évolution
hasardeuse,
OK ?
Livrer à la chance,
car la chance
n'est même pas un être,
la chance n'a même
pas d'intelligence.
Donc,
c'est contradictoire
de suggérer
que les choses marchent
envers une complexité
car il n'y a aucune force,
aucun être intelligent
qui puisse conduire
les choses
envers la complexité
à part Dieu.
Et ici,
il n'y a aucun intérêt
à décrire Dieu
comme quelqu'un
qui soit dans le désir
de faire que les choses
se développent.
C'est un Dieu
qui va créer les choses
avec intelligence,
qui va exposer
son ordre,
son intelligence
par rapport
à la manière
très organisée
dont il crée les choses.
Et donc,
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre.
Donc,
cette première déclaration,
on a quelques divergences
d'interprétation
entre verset 1
et verset 2.
La terre était
en forme et vide,
il y avait des ténèbres
à la surface
de l'abîme,
mais l'esprit
des dieux
planait
au-dessus
des eaux.
Verset 3,
remarquez bien
en fait
la vitesse
ou l'enchaînement
des arguments.
Dieu dit
que la lumière
soit
et la lumière
fut.
Donc,
quelle est
la déclaration
que nous allons
reconnaître
dans la structure
de Genèse ?
Nous devons parler
de la structure
de Genèse
car la structure
est une structure
qui n'a pas
pour but
d'être une description
détaillée
scientifique
de la création,
mais là
où elle touche
la science
ou là
où la science
peut la toucher,
nous voyons
comment la science
est pour Dieu
et est pour
les récits
de la création
telle qu'il est.
Donc,
on pourrait parler
des théories
qui pourraient
contredire
les Écritures
mais nous devons
plutôt nous laisser
conduire
par les textes
bibliques
et ensuite
voir
si les découvertes
de la science
supportent
ou non
les descriptions
qu'on trouve
dans la Bible.
Donc,
c'est intéressant
car quand on parle
des méthodes
scientifiques,
il n'y a pas
des sciences
là où il n'y a
pas des observateurs.
L'une des bases
les plus importantes
de la science,
c'est l'observation
des phénomènes.
Et ici,
nous sommes devant
un phénomène
où aucun être
n'était présent.
Donc,
ici,
voilà pourquoi
l'importance
d'étudier
l'inspiration
des Écritures
est très sûr
que nous sommes
devant la parole
inspirée de Dieu
et nous savons
que Dieu
a révélé
un récit
suffisant
à Moïse
pour qu'il
enregistre
sous inspiration
afin de nous
donner les bases
essentielles.
Donc,
l'un des arguments
qui va mettre
en question
l'interprétation
littérale
des Jeunesses
va suggérer
que l'encadrement
littéraire
des Jeunesses
est plutôt
poétique
ou plutôt
parfois mythologique.
Le problème,
c'est que
lorsque Jésus
va faire
un abordage,
Marc 10 par exemple,
lorsqu'il est
mis en question
par rapport
au divorce
et sa réponse
c'est
c'est comme
à la création
et il va citer
de manière
historique
et littérale
ce qui se passe
en Jeunesse
chapitre 1 à 3.
Et donc là,
nous voyons aussi
Paul qui va faire
les parallèles
entre
la chute
et
les premiers
Adam
et les deuxièmes
qui est très littéral
aussi
l'interprétation
des Paul
par rapport
à ces textes
et nous avons
plusieurs d'autres indices
comme l'auteur
d'Hébreu
qui nous dit
que par la foi
nous croyons
que les choses
ont été créées
par la parole
des dieux
de manière
très explicite
et très directe.
Quand on pense
par exemple
aux dix commandements
qui vont
renouveler
quelques bases
et compréhensions
par rapport
au commandement
des dieux
liées
à la chute
de l'homme
et restaurer
les septièmes jours
les jours du sabbat
en tant
qu'un commandement
la base
pour dire
qu'un jour
sur sept
est les jours
d'adoration
les jours sanctifiés
c'est dépointé
à la création
donc Exode
chapitre 20
va revenir
à la création
pour dire
que Dieu a séparé
un jour
sur sept
pour
pour qu'on puisse
l'adorer.
Donc tous ces indices
intra-bibliques
ont un abordage
très littéral
et historique
des Genènes.
À partir du moment
où on commence
à définir
nous-mêmes
dans un même livre
quand est-ce
que la littérature
change
lorsqu'on n'a pas
beaucoup d'invidences
bibliques
pour les faire
nous retombons
dans une interprétation
très arbitraire
des écritures
et à la fin
on ne peut plus
dicter
ce qui est allégorique
ou ce qui est littéral
dans la parole de Dieu.
Donc la Bible
ne peut plus être fiable
dans son ensemble.
Lorsqu'il est
les genres
littéraires
sont explicites
et évidents
comme par exemple
les psaumes
ou les proverbes
les choses
sont tellement claires
qu'on n'a pas
de doute.
Mais lorsqu'il
les auteurs bibliques
traitent Genèse
comme littéral
nous n'avons pas
le droit
de les traiter
différemment.
Et donc ici
c'est intéressant
la possibilité
de cet encadrement
nous avons déjà vu
pourquoi
ce n'est pas
l'option
la plus naturelle
du texte
mais le plus naturel
dans les textes
c'est que
Dieu va marcher
sur la structure
qu'on va retrouver
à Genèse
toujours
pour décrire
la création
de général
de disforme
envers
les spécifiques
et ce qui va
prendre forme.
Et pourquoi ?
Car ce que Dieu
est en train
de nous enseigner
c'est qu'il a
intentionnellement
dans une période
de sept jours
il a intentionnellement
apporté la création
à sa perfection
originale.
Et c'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire.
Donc là
lorsqu'il décrit
la création
de la matière primaire
si on peut dire
comme ça
c'est
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre.
Donc c'est un continu
Dieu créa
les ciels
et la terre.
La terre
était en forme
et vide
donc Dieu
a créé
et donc
l'expression
pour cette
première création
c'est
les termes
bara
et ça c'est
très important.
Bara
c'est lorsque
Dieu crée
quelque chose
sans effort
mais à partir
d'ailleurs.
C'est
pour mettre
en évidence
en emphase
la puissance
créatrice
des dieux
et on sait
très bien
que tout
comme
avec la lumière
Dieu va
tout simplement
déclarer
que la lumière
soit
et la lumière
fut.
Et voilà
pourquoi
Hebreu va
corroborer
cette déclaration
en disant
toutes les choses
ont été créées
par la parole
de Dieu.
Donc c'est clair
que pour Dieu
et c'est là
la problématique
que je ne comprends
pas en fait
je suis vraiment étonné
à partir du moment
où nous croyons
que Dieu crée
la lumière
à partir
des rien
tout simplement
en disant
que la lumière
soit
quelle serait
la difficulté
pour Dieu
de créer
toutes les choses
dans une période
de sept jours.
Soit nous croyons
dans un Dieu
tout puissant
soit nous ne
ne les croyons pas.
Et la réalité
c'est que Dieu
ici il est en train
de déclarer
qu'il a tout
créé
les ciels
et la terre
mais dans sa condition
originale
la terre
était en forme
et vide.
La terre
était en forme
et vide.
Vide
pourquoi ?
Car dans les langages
de Genèse lui-même
Dieu va remplir
la terre
donc vide
dans le sens
où il n'y avait
pas d'habitants
il n'y avait pas
d'arbre
encore des pelouses
il n'y avait pas
encore des animaux
donc la terre
était vide
ce n'était pas vide
dans le sens
où il n'y a pas
quelque chose
dedans
c'est vide
dans le sens
où elle n'était
pas encore remplie
par des êtres
animés
et donc
elle était
en forme
aussi
et donc c'était
à Dieu lui-même
dans cette période
on est devant
la description
de la création
de la matière
pour mettre
la distinction
entre Dieu
et ce qu'il a créé
et ensuite
c'est intéressant
pour mettre
encore plus
l'emphase
sur le fait
que Dieu lui-même
est celui
qui sera en train
d'interagir
avec cette création
pour porter
les cosmos
et là c'est important
l'expression cosmos
c'est un peu
comment on fait
la cosmétique
pour essayer
de réordonner
réarranger
les visuels
mais c'est intéressant
aussi de voir
qu'il y avait
cette création
disforme
et Dieu va
tout simplement
mettre en ordre
ce qu'il a créé
et donc
il va dire
mais l'esprit
des dieux
planait
au-dessus
des eaux
on pourrait
avoir d'autres
traductions
pour dire
il couvrait
ok
ou il tournait
autour
mais c'est
un langage
que la Bible
va nous présenter
aussi
lorsqu'elle va
présenter
les aigles
les moments
aigles
quand elles vont
couvrir
leurs oeufs
pour
comme vous dites
en français
pour
les couver
et donc là
c'est intéressant
c'est pour démontrer
que l'oeuvre
de la création
c'était une oeuvre
trinitaire
et on sait très bien
la Bible va nous dire
plus tard
que c'était par les fils
qui Dieu a créé
toutes les choses
et ici
nous voyons
l'interaction
de son esprit
qui semble être
celui qui est
plus directement
lié
à porter
cet ordre
qui Dieu est en train
de porter
à la création
pour mettre en relève
pour mettre en évidence
que celui
qui ordonne
les choses
ne prend pas
trop longtemps
pour les faire
car c'est Dieu
lui-même
le tout puissant
que les faire
avec toute son intelligence
et toute son implication
c'est les saints esprits
qui est là
en train de former
la terre
de porter
les cosmos
et là
une description
plus périodique
de comment
Dieu
à travers
les fils
et les saints esprits
était en train
de mener l'ordre
dans l'univers
et donc
premier jour
c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
l'importance
de ces jours
donc
Dieu dit
que la lumière
soit
donc ici
nous sommes
il n'y a pas
des coupures
dans cette expression
des conclusions
il y a eu
un soir
et il y a eu
un matin
ce fut
un jour
donc ici
c'est
l'expression
des conclusions
de chaque période
de description
de création
et donc
au commencement
jusqu'à cette déclaration
il y a eu
un soir
et il y a eu
un matin
ce fut
un jour
voilà pourquoi
la lecture
la plus naturelle
du verset 1 à 3
c'est
d'être
devant
les premiers jours
ok
et donc
ensuite
donc
que la lumière
soit
donc
et la lumière
fut
Dieu vit
que la lumière
était bonne
et Dieu sépara
la lumière
d'avec des ténèbres
Dieu appela
la lumière
jour
et il appela
les ténèbres
nuit
il y eut
un soir
et il y eut
un matin
ce fut
un jour
donc c'est
très intéressant
de remarquer
dans la structure
des genès
et dans la structure
générale
hébraïque
de démontrer
à nouveau
comment Dieu
est celui
qui agit
en apportant
l'ordre
la Bible
va nous présenter
que la lumière
parfois
c'est
ce qui va être
est-ce qu'on dit
émissionné
non
c'est qu'il va être
émis
de la part
de la gloire
de Dieu
donc quand on arrivera
à la gloire
on n'aura plus besoin
du soleil
car la gloire
de Dieu
va allumer
toute la terre
c'est intéressant
les ténèbres
semblent être
quelque chose
qui sont là
et qui
à la mesure
au fur et à mesure
où Dieu
fait avancer
la lumière
les ténèbres
seront chassées
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
la lumière
est l'une des choses
les plus importantes
car elle a un lien
avec la représentativité divine
très importante
mais Dieu
a créé
la lumière
ok
qui subsiste en lui
mais qui est en dehors
de lui
et la lumière
qui ici
nous est présentée
plutôt comme une substance
car plus tard
il va créer
les soleils
ok
mais ici
c'est
tout simplement
la lumière
et une séparation
entre ténèbres
et lumière
et Dieu
appela la lumière
jour
il appela
les ténèbres
nuit
il eut en soir
et en matin
ce fut un jour
parfois
les personnes disent
on a qu'est la création
du soleil plus tard
et donc
dans notre système solaire
nous avons
qu'est le soleil
pour marquer
véritablement
ce qu'il y a un jour
et donc
ils diront
à partir du troisième jour
nous allons avoir
des jours littérales
des 24 heures
sans aucun problème
par contre
ici nous avons déjà
des indices
que même si on n'a pas
de compréhension
de comment cette lumière
fonctionnait
il y avait déjà
des distinctions
entre lumière et ténèbres
et le problème
c'est qu'ici
jusqu'au troisième jour
jusqu'au moment
où Dieu va créer
les soleils
une fois
que dans le deuxième jour
le troisième jour
les végétaux
étaient déjà créés
le problème
c'est qu'aucune vie
même végétale
ne peut survivre
avec des longues périodes
de soleil
ou des longues périodes
de ténèbres
donc ça serait impossible
la maintenance
de cette création
mais en tout cas
c'est clair
qu'à partir du moment
où Dieu fait la division
et qu'il définit
la période
avec matin et soir
ou soir et matin
et pourquoi soir et matin
car c'est intéressant
dans les mouvements
de l'observation
des séjours
des créations
les jours finis
avec les soirs
et en finissant
les jours
avec les soirs
on va nommer
d'abord les soirs
et remonter
où ça a commencé
que c'était les matins
donc c'est juste
un mouvement
des descriptions
qu'on trouve ici
il y eut un soir
et il y eut un matin
ce fut un jour
et donc jour 1
qu'est-ce qu'on a créé
lumière
et division
avec ténèbres
et notion
donc notion des jours
ok
qu'il y a là
une déclaration
qui est toujours
très importante
et Dieu vit
que la lumière
était bonne
et donc c'est très important
l'expression bonne
c'est
il n'est manqué
aucune chose
à la lumière
pour qu'elle soit
évoluée
elle est créée
donc c'est là
la grande distinction
entre la vision
des mondes
chrétiennes
bibliques
et la vision
des mondes
évolutionnistes
nous on est en train
de progresser
dans la conception
mondaine
mais dans la Bible
on est en train
de souffrir
une dégradation
à partir de la chute
et donc on était
créé
bon
et là on n'est plus
et donc ensuite
on peut passer
au verset 6
pardon
verset
oui c'est le verset 4
mais
bon je pense
que j'ai déjà trouvé
oui c'est le 6
non ?
ouais ok
Dieu dit
qu'il y ait
une étendue
entre les oeufs
pour séparer
les oeufs
des oeufs
Dieu fit donc
cette étendue
sépara les oeufs
qui sont au-dessus
de l'étendue
avec les oeufs
qui sont au-dessus
il en fut ainsi
Dieu appela
l'étendue
ciel
il eut
un soir
un matin
ce fut
un deuxième jour
donc qu'est-ce qui se passe
au deuxième jour
séparation
des oeufs
ok
on pense
au ciel
on a encore
oui
donc on peut décrire
c'est la séparation
voilà
donc
les ciels
et les oeufs
pour que ça soit
et donc pour certains
c'est une distinction
entre les nuages
et l'étendue lui-même
le ciel
avec cette atmosphère
ou sinon
l'eau
elle-même
des océans
et
les ciels
ok
et là à nouveau
euh
il en fut un signe
Dieu appela
l'étendue du ciel
et il eut
un soir
un matin
ce fut
le deuxième jour
ok
Dieu dit
que les oeufs
qui sont au-dessus
du ciel
s'amassent
en un seul endroit
et que la partie
sèche
apparaisse
et en fut un signe
Dieu appela
la terre
la partie sèche
et il appela
mère
la masse
des oeufs
Dieu vit
que cela a été bon
il eut
un soir
un matin
ce fut
le troisième jour
ok
donc on va dire
euh
terre
séparation
avec
les océans
ou la mer
on écrit
la mer
ok
et ensuite
on a aussi
les verdures
quelle est
la déclaration
que je trouve
la plus importante
pour nous
à retenir
vis-à-vis
à la théorie
de l'évolution
ici
selon
son espèce
donc
chacune
des créations
des dieux
donc
chaque
verdure
chaque fruit
chaque arbre
qui a été créé
par dieu
a été créé
pour produire
et pour se reproduire
selon
son espèce
donc nous
en tant que chrétiens
nous n'avons pas besoin
de nier
ce qu'on appelle
la micro-évolution
c'est tout simplement
des disformités
parfois
qui ont lieu
et qui par la sélection
naturelle
ça peut
perdurer
et tout
mais la réalité
c'est que
la macro-évolution
on a déjà
pas des indices
suffisants
dans la science
dans les mondes
de la science
et aucune base
biblique
pour les croire
donc la réalité
c'est que
changement
d'espèce
ne peut pas
avoir lieu
car dieu
a créé
toutes les choses
selon
leur espèce
depuis les arbres
ok
et surtout
les êtres humains
comme on verra
plus tard
verset 14
et donc à nouveau
Dieu vit
que cela a été bon
et c'est
les troisièmes jours
ensuite
verset 14
Dieu dit
qu'il y a des astres
dans l'étendue céleste
pour séparer
les jours
de la nuit
que ce soit
des signes
pour marquer
les temps
les jours
et les années
que ce soit
des astres
dans l'étendue céleste
pour éclairer
la terre
il en fut ainsi
Dieu fit
les deux grands astres
les grands
pour dominer
sur les jours
et pour éclairer
la terre
pour dominer
sur les jours
et sur la nuit
et pour séparer
la lumière
d'avec les ténèbres
Dieu vit
que cela a été bon
il y eut
un soir
et il y eut
un matin
ce fut
un quatrième jour
donc là
nous avons
quatrième jour
je vais mettre
ici à côté
de premier
car on voit
qu'il y a
un parallélisme
ici
important
car si
Dieu avait créé
la substance
la lumière
ici
Dieu
est en train de créer
les soleils
et les astres
donc à nouveau
du général
envers les particuliers
avec plus d'ordre
plus de détails
plus de contrôle
et c'est vraiment
très beau de voir
comment les designs
des dieux
ont été tellement
intelligents
donc on sait très bien
en fait
que ces astres
sont là
en train de les marquer
et là
les époques
ou les périodes
ça parle aussi
de ce qu'on appelle
les saisons
ok
comment on a
toute cette variété
mais c'est intéressant
car ils servent
aussi des signes
donc on sait très bien
qu'ils peuvent servir
des repères
pour les voyages
etc
mais c'est intéressant
comment même
pour la fin des temps
il y aura un rôle
pour la lune
pour les soleils
qui deviendra
en ténèbres
la lune couvrira
des seins
etc
donc certains
commentateurs
vont même
faire les liens
comment dieux
depuis la création
avait déjà
un rôle
rédemptive
rédempteur
ou un rôle
scatologique
vis-à-vis à la fin des temps
même pour ces astres
pour ces luminaires
qui vont jouer
un rôle important aussi
pour toutes ces choses
donc c'est tout simplement
glorieux de voir
comment rien n'échappe
en des seins des dieux
qui est lié
à ces seins éternels
mais aussi
dans cette providence divine
comment cet ordre là
permet que la terre
continue à produire
de la vie
à changer de saison
et tout cela
sous cette gouvernance
des dieux
donc c'était les jours
des 24 heures
dans lesquelles
Dieu a créé
les soleils
la lune
et les astres
donc ceux
qui vont remplir
cette division
qui pour certains
est entre les ciels
avec lesquels
on attire
avec nos yeux
on attend
et les ciels
des ciels
qui est l'espace
et ensuite
quand Paul parle
du troisième ciel
c'est là
où on va
en l'étrône des dieux
au-dessus
de la création
même en dépassant
ou surmontant
l'espace
et donc
on s'est arrêté
au verset
donc on va passer
vent
Dieu dit
que les oeufs
se mettent
à grouiller
d'êtres vivants
et que sur la terre
des oiseaux
volent
sous l'étendue céleste
Dieu créa
selon leur espèce
les grands monstres
marrants
et tous les êtres vivants
qui nagent
et dont
les eaux
s'émirent à grouiller
il créa aussi
tout oiseau
ailé
selon son espèce
Dieu vit
que cela
était bon
Dieu les bénit
en disant
soyez féconds
multipliez-vous
et remplissez
les eaux
des mers
et les oiseaux
se multiplient
sur la terre
il y eut un soir
il y eut un matin
ce fut
un cinquième jour
chacun
selon son
espèce
et là
on a
la manière
dont Dieu a peuplé
les océans
les mers
et dont Dieu a peuplé
aussi
la terre
qui peuplerait
les cieux
donc les oiseaux
il y en a
ceux qui grampent
pour suggérer
aussi les reptiles
etc
et donc là
on a
des manières
très intéressantes
les animaux
on dirait
voilà
merci
céleste
et marre
et donc
les parallèles
il est intéressant aussi
car Dieu avait
séparé au deuxième jour
donc il est en train
de suivre
les mêmes ordres
une chose importante
à retenir
en arrivant
à la création
de l'homme
c'est de considérer
comme c'est intéressant
tout comme
quand on considère
l'arrivée d'un bébé
on commence à préparer
la chambre
toute la vie du couple
tourne autour
du bébé
mais la chose
la plus importante
quand on commence
à faire la chambre
on va tout
organiser
tout tourner
etc
c'est l'arrivée
du bébé
et dans un certain sens
même tout l'univers
a été créé
pour démontrer
non que l'homme
serait au centre
mais que l'homme
serait
l'être
créé à l'image
de Dieu
qui pourra
réjouir
suprêmement
par rapport
à tous les autres
êtres créés
en tant que couronne
de la création
l'être humain
va pouvoir
contempler la gloire
de Dieu
d'une manière
particulière
dans tout ça
et réjouir
d'une relation
avec Dieu
et ça c'est intéressant
car les plus
en fait des découvertes
scientifiques
vis-à-vis
au cosmos
à l'espace
il y a la sensation
chez l'être humain
que nous avons
très peu d'importance
et dans un certain sens
même David
dans l'épsomme 8
il va arriver
à cette conclusion
qui suis-je ?
Qui est l'homme
pour que tu puisses
penser à lui ?
Qui est l'homme
pour que tu puisses
lui donner de l'importance ?
les visiter ?
Donc c'est intéressant
quand on contemple
notre petitesse
devant la grandeur
de l'univers
on peut avoir l'impression
qu'on est très petit
mais la réalité
c'est que selon
les récits de jeunesse
Dieu est en train
de créer
tout cet univers
pour que nous ayons
la capacité
de réjouir
et de trouver Dieu
à travers
toutes ces choses
et donc c'est glorieux
de voir en fait
comment
Dieu est en train
de préparer
toutes ces choses
afin de mettre
l'homme
au centre
comme courant
de la création
donc
que la terre
produise
vers ces 24
les êtres vivants
selon leur espèce
bétail reptile
animaux terrestres
chacun selon son espèce
il en fut ainsi
Dieu fit les animaux
de la terre
selon leur espèce
les bétails
selon son espèce
et tous les reptiles
du sol
selon leur espèce
Dieu vit que cela
était bon
Dieu dit
et là c'est intéressant
et là
l'introduction
à nouveau
de pluriel
la forme pluriel
faisons l'homme
à notre image
selon notre rassemblance
pour qu'il domine
sur les poissons
de la mer
sur les oiseaux
du ciel
sur les bétails
sur toute la terre
et sur tous les reptiles
qui rampent
sur la terre
Dieu créa
verset 27
l'homme à son image
donc l'homme
l'être humain
à son image
il les créa
l'image de Dieu
homme et femme
il les créa
Dieu les bénit
et Dieu leur dit
soyez féconds
multipliez-vous
remplissez la terre
et soumettez-la
dominez sur les poissons
de la mer
sur les oiseaux
du ciel
et sur tout animal
qui rampe sur la terre
Dieu dit
voici que je vous donne
toute herbe porteuse
des sémences
et qui est à la surface
de toute la terre
et tout arbre fruitier
porteur des sémences
ce sera votre nourriture
à tout animal de la terre
à tout oiseau du ciel
à tous ceux qui rampent
sur la terre
et qui souffrent des vies
je donne toute herbe verte
pour nourriture
et il en fut ainsi
Dieu vit alors
tout ce qu'il avait fait
et voici
c'était
très bon
vous voyez la distinction
tout était bon
et là
très bon
ok
car ça
ça donne la sensation
d'accomplissement
mais c'est clairement
lié
à la couronne
de la création
qui était lettrement
créée à l'image
de Dieu
et donc
ce fut
en sixième jour
ainsi furent achevés
les ciels et la terre
et toutes leurs armées
les septième jour
toute l'oeuvre
qui Dieu avait fait
donc chapitre 2 verset 1
toute l'oeuvre
qui Dieu avait faite
était achevée
et il se reposa
au septième jour
de toute l'oeuvre
qu'il avait faite
Dieu bénit
les septième jour
les sanctifia
car en ces jours
Dieu s'était reposé
de toute l'oeuvre
qu'il avait créée
donc juste quelques mots
pour conclure
mais
sixième jour
tous les animaux
terrestres
et l'homme
en tant qu'image
des dieux
quand on voit
la manière dont Dieu
va s'arrêter
c'est là où nous voyons
qu'il est au centre
de toute la création
il y a eu
une implication
un engagement
au moins Dieu
a voulu laisser ça
très explicite
en la parole des dieux
que l'être humain
pour plus que
toutes les choses
qui avaient été créées
étaient glorieuses
étaient belles
et étaient bonnes
c'est clair
que Dieu a voulu
que l'être humain
soit fait
avec un soin particulier
donc la trinité
est évidemment identifiée
lorsqu'ils s'arrêtent
et ils se disent
faisons l'homme
notre image
comme notre rassemblance
et à partir de là
l'être humain est créé
et on verra
plus tard
dans le chapitre 2
de quelle manière
plus particulière
l'être humain est créé
avec les souffles
de l'esprit de Dieu
lui-même
pour animer l'homme
c'est qu'il fait
la distinction
entre les êtres vivants
ou les âmes vivantes
et ceux qui reçoivent
les souffles de l'esprit
donc l'être humain
est âme vivante
mais il est plus que ça
et donc c'est important
de reconnaître
ces privilèges
donc on va
s'approfondir plus
par rapport à
ce qui fait
l'image de l'homme
des dieux
dans l'homme
mais le plus important
pour nous à remarquer
c'est que dans un
complet mouvement
des progressions
et d'ordre d'importance
Dieu dans une période
de six jours
va créer toutes les choses
et va placer l'être humain
avec cette capacité
d'être son image
son image
car il possède
quelques attributs
qui sait que Dieu
qui les possède
par exemple
la personnalité
et les attributs moraux
mais c'est aussi
par sa capacité
de créer
de recréer
et de gouverner
d'exercer cette domination
envers toute la terre
qui a été créée
tous les animaux
et c'est important aussi
de considérer
qu'il y a surtout
ce qui est
les privilèges
les plus élevés
de l'être humain
c'est la capacité
de réjouir les dieux
et voilà pourquoi
Dieu a structuré
la vie de cette manière
quelqu'un a déjà fait
cette remarque
quand on observe
qu'est la nature
on peut arriver
à la conclusion
de comment nous pourrions
compter les mois
par l'observation
de la lune
les années
par rapport à la manière
dont on tourne
comment on dira ça
les quatre saisons
on observe
les changements
des quatre saisons
et on fait
la rotation complète
des quatre saisons
autour du soleil
c'est ça
les jours
c'est facile à compter
c'est un tour
autour de soi-même
par contre
la semaine
on ne trouve pas
des bases naturelles
pour identifier
à part
la révélation spéciale
des dieux
dans la création
et les rythmes
qu'on n'arrive pas
à expliquer
mais finalement
toutes les sociétés
sont structurées
de cette manière
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que la base
fondamentale
c'est la création
qui sera
raffirmée
dans les moments
où Dieu va donner
les dix commandements
un jour sur sept
et les jours
d'adoration
sera un jour sur sept
et donc ces jours
d'adoration
c'est fondé
dans la création
car l'objectif
central de la création
c'est oui
l'homme avait un boulot
à faire
il devrait
exercer ses fonctions
mais la semaine
a toujours orbité
autour d'un jour
qui était
les jours
de la rencontre
avec Dieu
les jours
d'adoration
et donc
Dieu n'a pas besoin
de se reposer
donc il n'a pas créé
les jours de repos
pour lui
il a créé
les jours de repos
pour nous
donc les repos
pour Dieu
dans la création
c'est pour signifier
tout était parfait
tout était complet
tout était glorieux
donc c'était une oeuvre
finie
car elle n'avait plus besoin
de se développer
et c'était important aussi
car c'était les jours
que Dieu avait fixé
pour donner
la signification principale
à l'être humain
qui est la réjouissance
donc il passe
toute la semaine
en interagissant
avec l'univers des dieux
en ayant
plein de motivation
pour être reconnaissant
vers Dieu
pour contempler
la gloire de Dieu
en produisant
et ici
ça serait les jours
dans un certain sens
d'une sainte
rédivabilité
voilà ce que j'ai fait
des dons que tu m'as donné
des opportunités
envers ton univers
mais surtout
expression de reconnaissance
et réjouissance
des communes
et d'adoration
un jour sur sept
nous sommes créés
comme des êtres
cultuels
des êtres qui ont été faits
pour célébrer
et réjouir
la création
des dieux
comme Dieu a célébré
réjoui
en s'arrêtant
pour la contempler
et réjouir
la création
de la création
des déchoures